well some of you at home may have been
tuning in to FBI here before our
newscast and it might have left you
wondering what really goes into becoming
one of those agents and earlier today
Victoria Saha got an inside look at how
the Las Vegas FBI does its firearm
training and how important they say it
is to keep up on a regular basis
trained to respond and to react this is
serious business there's not a bunch of
cowboys just out here shooting Spencer
Evans is a special agent in charge for
the Las Vegas division of the FBI he and
several FBI range instructors walked us
through their firearms program
with a good grip a good stance and my
eye on the target I was ready to fire
out in a real life scenario when you're
trying to take down someone how close is
the distance for you to actually feel
comfortable to start shooting we start
at the three yard line because the
majority of law enforcement shootings
are usually within Close Quarters though
this may look easy the FBI goes through
rigorous training every agent qualifies
with their weapon at least four times a
year those that are on specialty teams
including SWAT are going to qualify
every week virtually we were able to get
an inside look and feel of all their
weapons
including this Tommy Gun used in World
War II and one of the first weapons FBI
agents used decades ago so you can kind
of like rest here come up one two nice
showing us how their weapons and
protection evolves throughout the years
to make sure that we're meeting the
emerging threats that we face every day
but the brutal truth is that no matter
how much preparation goes into training
Evan says there's always a threat as we
saw recently with Metro officer trueang
Tai's death Firearms are just a natural
part of the job and bad guys have them
too and as we saw again the last couple
weeks they're not afraid to use them
Victoria Saha eight news now